another sign of how serious the u.s
thinks the threat russia poses to
ukraine the u.s president announced he's
moving u.s forces to the region have you
decided how soon you would be moving u.s
troops to eastern europe
i've been moving u.s troops to eastern
europe and the nato countries in the
near term
not a lot he's likely talking about the
8 500 troops that were put on standby to
deploy most headed to bolster nato's
quick reaction force but he's also said
he has no intention of sending us troops
to ukraine
and a new tone from the pentagon with
more than one hundred thousand russian
troops on ukraine's border the top
military leaders say russia has enough
force to take over ukraine
given the type of forces that are
arrayed
the ground maneuver forces the artillery
the ballistic missiles the air forces
all of it packaged together
if
that was unleashed on ukraine it would
be significant very significant and it
would result in a significant amount of
casualties
and and you can imagine what that might
look like in dense urban areas
along roads and so on and so forth it
would be horrific it would be terrible
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky is
trying to reassure his people saying
we've seen russian build up forces like
this before the warning from the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
this time is different
and the biden administration is under
pressure by some to have the military do
more issue sanctions and then escalate
well the signal i want to send is we're
not going to back off
the more provocative you are
the more
result resolve we'll have for nato
so send american and nato soldiers
around russia to reinforce we're not
giving an inch when it comes to nato but
the administration wants to send the
message diplomacy can still work
there's no reason that this situation
has to devolve into conflict
he can choose to de-escalate
he can order his troops away
he can choose dialogue and diplomacy if
not the u.s says the results will be
catastrophic not just for ukraine but
for russia as well patty culhane al
jazeera washington